je me tourne vers le professeur par les
mouvements étudiants la télévision et je
suis jeune et j'ai pu écouter
je suis désolé mais excusez moi mais
c'est pas très poli d'interrompre c'est
pas très poli n'a pas invité un étudiant
pourparlers pour les étudiants je me
transforme alors donnez vous ou en cause
je suis venu parler du problème
étudiants dans une démocratie à citoyens
étudiants en droit de parler de son
problème
oui vous comprenez elle a coûté joue
d'aller à l'esitpa les deux buts en deux
minutes par les deux minutes et puis
elle parle et je vais dire ce que j'ai à
dire si vous l'aviez fait dans une
émission avant d'écouter moi je suis pas
responsable de cette section qui jouent
tous venus dans un des rares intervalle
où un individu peut s'exprimer en direct
je suis vraiment désolé d'interrompre
votre oui oui mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire alors je vais dire ce que
j'ai à dire sur les historiques idiot
mais un becquet l'histoire étudiante ne
savais pas qu'un projet jospin ah ben
oui mais ça il ya des projets 2010
cascio nation et la plainte au nom de
jonathan qui est des quais des vitrines
cassées qui est d'évoquer la bagarre qui
a un mort de malik oussékine et là tout
d'un coup ça intéresse parce qu'il ya du
sang qui a coulé vous comprenez est
autrement l'éducation à la télévision
s'en tape
oui alors je viens parler de l'éducation
et que désormais là c'est pas le sujet
on va pas les laisser se fera jamais le
sujet à la télévision vous avez dû le
pen vous avez du match à la une en
permanence le direction vous ne parlez à
rien pas de progrès vous faites
simplement d'être d'aligner des chiffres
et des statistiques vous vous foutez de
la gueule du monde en permanence je
parle pas de vous mais ce pivot mais en
général des médias ce qui va se passer
c'est que c'est évident c'est que la
direction va donner l'ordre de couper
l'antenne la 6è la coupelle si elles
coupent l'antenne moi je me le plante
dans le vent et n'en fait pas ça coûte
prenait le risque vous allez voir mais
non mais le fait de passer des loups est
ce que vous allez voir jeudi à la
direction monsieur bourges c'est pas
pour rien que jamais
ce sera contre moi et c'est vous qui
n'ont verserez médias on me censure en
haut mais la vie est trop précieuse la
vue précieuse que si on la laisse
s'exprimer en liberté et librement vous
dit désolé le fait de cette inclusion
mais des fois l'arrêt des rejoint la
fiction non mais je vais d'abord écouter
je vous donne trois minutes et puis vous
expliquer 3000 prendrait le ton crâne en
venant là vous n'êtes pas honnête alors
là c'est pas bien ça c'est pas bien
l'honnêteté la télévision j'en vois pas
beaucoup ces temps ci vous comprenez
vous avez perdu 18 points de crédibilité
en quatre ans au niveau des journalistes
à la télévision c'est dans le monde
diplomatique a ôté sa demande à geoffrey
toujours parlait pas beaucoup de salles
à telle vitesse jeu la crédibilité des
journalistes et de monsieur poivre
d'arvor
les fouilleurs de merde oui on la parle
pas beaucoup et il est gentil mais
n'attaquez pas mes confrères sur ce
bateau ça me gênerait viseur vous n'y
êtes pour rien c'est moi qui m'exprime
librement un citoyen droit de s'exprimer
librement à la télévision française
c'est comme ça ça vous dit faire parce
que sinon ça explose rang vous comprenez
je voulais télé soupape de sécurité
il faut laisser le diallo pascal et moi
je suis un type constructif et j'ai des
propositions constructives réel des
propositions qui évite la bagarre ben
oui mais là la soul est plutôt oui
un exemple le bas vous ne laissez pas le
choix vous les êtes un exemple de
bagarres plutôt la couette
je suis désolé nous vous rendez compte
comment voulez vous faire passer vos
idées à télévision en ayant avec vous un
couteau c'est pas possible il peut rien
n'y a pas de moyens de s'exprimer dans
ce pays démocratique mais si quand même
bien de mon appart vous appartient des
comités ad syndicat n'a pas de moyens je
sais que quand même il ya une langue de
voir oui au final on répare le livre
n'existe pas vous n'allez jamais
s'exprimant écoutez je pense pas que ça
puisse durer longtemps ce
laissez-moi m'exprimer si vous me
censurer il y aura de la bagarre dans
les cinq
il redonne pas garé dans la rue jeudi
prochain une manifestation
si jamais je ne peux pas m'exprimer
aujourd'hui il y aura de la bagarre dans
la rue vous comprenez vous n'avez pas
donné la parole aux étudiants il faut
qu'existe mémoire et bien c'est pas mon
rôle moi donner la parole aux étudiants
un rôle des médias mais c'est le rôle
des médias des médiateurs sans arrêt on
donna la parole donné la parole à la
carte vous donner la parole à la
destruction
vous êtes uniquement branché sur la
merde veut construire on peut construire
une université correction est en train
de se battre quand un ministre acceptera
de venir discuter de proposer quelque
chose de compréhensible
il propose du flou que les étudiants ne
comprennent pas comment voulez vous
qu'ils acceptent ça ils vivent dans des
conditions déplorables
le monsieur le ministre ne s'intéresse
absolument pas à ces conditions il
propose d'un coup débarras il y gère ça
comme un cheptel de bétail
vous comprenez moi je n'ai pas de haine
contre monsieur jospin mais pourquoi
pourquoi il nous donne un texte
incompréhensible flou au possible
pourquoi il s'intéresse pas aux
conditions de vie ce sont des êtres
humains qui étudie et quand on étudiera
dans des conditions humaines le savoir
sera beau vous comprenez le savoir aux
quelque chose de beau on doit être beau
très bien m'écouter voilà vous a entendu
ces gentils maintenant de nous laisser
travailler
merci je veux non annoncés yen ont coûté
lalanne en coûtait alors la fosse aux
lyonnais alors vous n'êtes pas
sympathique avec avec moi moi je vous ai
rien fait d'autre pas sympathique avec
les téléspectateurs qui attendent cette
émission vous venez de parler vous avez
faire un coup d'éclat pendant 5 minutes
vous allez parler maintenant
maintenant suit est gentille ça c'est le
snof vous voulez moi je veux une
explication ne vous raisonnez pas moi je
suis pas justin mais j'ai jamais une
explication correct et cohérente à la
théorie pour expliquer je n'ai aucun
problème mais il peut pas y en avoir une
maman vous êtes incapable d'aligner une
explication parce que vous prenez les
gens pour des cons parce qu'ils sont pas
cap de pas capable de suivre un
raisonnement plus de trois minutes
vous dites ces gens là ce sont des
débiles sur leurs coûts plus de trois
minutes vous changez de chaîne
moi je crois j'ai confiance dans les
gens écoutent et merci soyez gentils
maintenant on va
et de repartir merci voilà désolé
écoutez si vous avez été exprimées quant
même savez vous avez des propositions
mais sûr mais sûrement l'occasion
constructive mais fait les ou personne
de adéquat qui sont capables voilà bon
merci bon allez à c'est elle c'est ce
qu'on appelle le mauvais oeil sur une
émission professeur s'exilera alors je
pense qu'il est toujours à l'antenne oui
j'espère alors le premier ce week-end ce
qui vous est excusez moi je suis désolé
mais c'est vraiment indépendant de ma
volonté est utile de vous le dire je
suis désolé de ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce qui vous a fait choisir quand
vous étiez étudiant en médecine
l'ophtalmologie les yeux